Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody.
So I'm going to talk today about the Biden
Putin summit that took place yesterday in
Geneva, Switzerland.
We're going to start with Vladimir Putin's
press conference momentarily.
Later, I want to talk about Donald Trump's
analysis, if you can use that term, which
you really shouldn't.
Trump's analysis on Fox News of the summit,
and I hate that I even have to do this, but
I want to just remind everybody I don't want
war with Russia.
The United States also does bad things, et
cetera.
And every time I talk about this and I just
point out the way I see Vladimir Putin and
Russian government, I get all sorts of emails
from people saying, David, you're falling
for this and you're falling for that.
And you should have this other opinion like
this person or that I'm not those people.
So if you want only to listen to someone with
that opinion, go to a different show.
This is my view.
And my view is not that I want war with Russia.
My view is not that Putin is uniquely bad,
but there are some really interesting and
unique characteristics of how Vladimir Putin
handles handles himself with media and how
he runs his government that I think are worthy
of some discussion.
So yesterday, Joe Biden and Vladimir Putin
had a meeting.
It was more than three hours long.
The American right wing was hoping that Joe
Biden would embarrass himself and be unable
to speak.
He, you know, be in a fit of acute dementia,
pooping his pants or whatever.
That didn't happen.
At the same time, there were some on the left
that often play coy with Putin who were hoping
that Biden would be exposed in this summit
as some kind of neocon war hawk who would
threaten Putin and go completely crazy.
And that also didn't happen.
And it was mostly unremarkable in that it
was normal diplomacy with a normal president
and a normal secretary of state.
The four years of Trump, where everything
is power games and often just placating authoritarian
leaders around the world, people forgot sort
of how diplomacy works and it's kind of boring.
Biden goes in with the list of priorities
that he wants to mention and then the secretary
of state and foreign minister, whatever the
equivalent position is called in Russia, they
have sort of second tier things on their list
that they talk about.
And it's a long and in some colloquial sense,
boring process of diplomacy.
But the most interesting part for me was actually
the press conference that happened after the
event.
Vladimir Putin first giving his press conference,
later Joe Biden doing his own press conference
and both taking questions from the media.
I want to focus in on the Putin press conference
today because Vladimir Putin was actually
very strongly confronted by reporters.
But Putin is so good at just slipping around,
answering any questions that he ends up saying
really nothing.
Even when asked directly about the deaths
of his political opponents, the fact that
dissidents end up poisoned in Russia.
So let's dove right in here.
He's asked if he'll stop the cyber attacks
and stop the crackdowns on his opposition.
See if you can find an answer here.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much for giving
me this question.
First of all, could you characterize the dynamic
between yourself and President Biden?
Was it hostile or was it friendly?
And secondly, throughout these conversations,
did you commit to ceasing carrying out cyber
attacks on the United States?
Did you commit to stopping, threatening Ukraine's
security?
And did you commit to stop cracking down on
the opposition in Russia?
Speaker 3: It should gear up shirts in the
first overall evaluation as far as that is
concerned, I don't think there was any kind
of hostility.
On the contrary.
Our meeting was obviously, you know, a fundamental
one.
Many of our joint positions are divergent.
But nevertheless, I think that both sides
manifested a determination to try and understand
each other and try and converge our positions.
And I think it was very constructive as far
as cyber security is concerned.
We agreed that we would begin consultations
on that issue.
And I believe that's extraordinary.
Speaker 1: Just no answer.
And and Putin is really amazing at this, quite
frankly.
Asked about the treatment of dissident Alexei
Navalny, Putin does two things that he often
does.
These are classics from the Putin playbook.
One, Putin won't say the guy's name.
He'll refer to him as the person you mentioned
or the gentleman in question.
And he says simply, well, the guy was breaking
the law
Speaker 3: as far as our non systematic or
nonstandard opposition is concerned.
And the gentleman you quoted, first of all,
this man knew that he was breaking the law
of Russia.
The US was doing OK.
He is somebody who has been twice convicted
even that, and he consciously ignored the
requirements of the law.
The gentleman in question went abroad for
treatment.
His registration was not asked for
Speaker 1: the gentleman you referenced.
This is a classic Putin move.
And of course, being suspected of breaking
the law, even if true, doesn't justify in
many countries.
It doesn't justify or lead to the treatment
that Alexei Navalny has received.
Now, guys, this doesn't mean the US doesn't
do bad things.
This doesn't mean the U.S. doesn't have inhumane
jails and prisons.
But it's just our analysis of what it is that
is happening in Russia and how it is that
Putin responds to questions about it.
An ABC reporter is called upon for a question
and says to Putin, the list of your political
opponents who are dead, imprisoned or jailed
is long.
What are you afraid of?
And Putin either doesn't understand the question
or more likely, Putin's a very smart guy.
Putin pretends not to understand and successfully
avoids actually answering.
Speaker 3: Yes, Americans, BBC News, our American
colleagues.
Speaker 4: Mr. President, thank you so much
for taking my question, President Biden has
said that he would respond if cyber attacks
from Russia do not stop.
I'm curious, what did he tell you?
Did he make any threats?
And a quick follow up, if I may, sir, the
list of your political opponents who are dead,
prison or jail, is long.
Alexei Navalny, this organization called for
free and fair elections an end to corruption.
But Russia has outlawed that organization,
calling it extremists.
And you have now prevented anyone who supports
him to run for office.
So my question is, Mr. President, what are
you so afraid of?
Speaker 3: It sure us, right?
Well, once again, I would like to repeat what
I said about so-called foreign agents and
the people who say that they are part of the
unauthorized opposition.
I've already spoken to your colleagues, but
now I have to repeat that to you.
OK, once again, the US has passed a law which
said that the US would particularly favor
individual organizations in Russia.
Speaker 1: So it just goes nowhere.
And the reporter points out you didn't answer
the question, what about those dead political
opponents in Russia?
And Putin still will not answer.
Speaker 4: You didn't answer my question,
sir.
If all of your political opponents are dead
in prison poison, doesn't that send a message
that you do not want a fair political fight
just yet?
Speaker 3: Well, on the question of who is
murdering whom, people rioted and went into
the Congress in the US with political demands.
And many people were dictators, criminals,
and they are threatened with imprisonment
from 20 to 25 years, presumably the latest
on the subject.
And these people were immediately arrested
after those events.
Speaker 1: He's called out and he just brings
up the January 6th Trump riots.
And again, for people who say, David, you're
too aggressive about Putin, I'm praising Putin.
You've really got to hand it to the guy.
He doesn't get fazed by being called out for
the political murders that he's suspected
of being involved in or having ordered last
one.
Putin asked about his relationship with the
West and how Russian politics is seen as unstable.
Putin answers about everything other than
that.
Take a look at this
Speaker 3: ABC News poll that Joe Biden presides
over stability.
But it's Kazuma of machineA is urging stable,
stable, predictable relations.
But the West thinks that unpredictability
is a hallmark of Russian politics.
How do you think you can improve relations
with the West?
Well, I think you've really got to a high
level up there in view, the first part of
your question that the West considers, are
you going to reject that?
You say, allow me, first of all, to answer
the first part of your question.
You said that in Russia, Russian foreign policy
is unpredictable.
Allow me to respond, first of all, with a
couple of facts.
What about the withdrawal of the U.S. from
the ABM Treaty?
Absolutely unpredictable.
Speaker 1: That was.
So I'm going to stop it there because it it
just goes nowhere.
Putin has this ability to talk and talk and
talk and say nothing.
That is really stunning.
And it it I wonder, does he do this with Biden?
In other words, during the summit, did the
summit end early?
Maybe.
We don't know why it ended early.
I think a lot of it was sort of like, what
else are we going to talk about?
Did the summit end early because Putin was
doing this stuff?
It's just an incredible filibustering and
so really unsurprising, but amazing how Putin
is just able to do this and do this and do
this.
And as a reminder, I don't want war with Russia.
I don't see Russia as a unique enemy, but
I don't play coy with authoritarian types
and I find nothing progressive in it.
And me, as a progressive social Democrat,
I find things to criticize about the United
States.
I'm against American imperialism around the
world, on and on and on.
And also I see very little that is redeeming
about governments that function the way that
Putin's Russia functions.
But I don't want war with Russia.
Guys don't email me saying I'm suggesting
or implying that we need to attack Russia
because I'm not.
And if you believe that, I would challenge
you to find even one instance of me saying
so.